sozialtourismus das wirft CDU-Chef
Friedrich Merz Millionen Ukrainern vor
Ukrainern die vor dem Krieg ins Ausland
fliehen viele davon auch zu uns nach
Deutschland Wohnungen Geld Unterstützung
vieles davon gibt es hier schnell und
vergleichsweise unbürokratisch eventuell
zu unbürokratisch denn es gibt wohl
immer mehr Hinweise darauf dass dieses
System also finanziell schnell zu helfen
ausgenutzt wird
wir erleben mittlerweile einen
sozialtourismus dieser Flüchtlinge nach
Deutschland zurück in die Ukraine nach
Deutschland zurück in die Ukraine mehr
als 1,1 Millionen Flüchtlinge insgesamt
bisher den Stand heute eine größere Zahl
sich dieses System zu Nutze machen da
haben wir ein Problem das wird größer
wir haben im Frühjahr darauf hingewiesen
dass dieses Problem entstehen konnte die
Bundesregierung hat sich taub gestellt
und so kontert Innenministerin nennt sie
Feser sie schreibt unter anderem auf
Twitter Stimmungsmacher auf dem Rücken
ukrainischer Frauen und Kindern die vor
Putins Bomben und Panzern geflohen sind
das ist schäbig sozialtourismus war 2013
das Unwort des Jahres und ist auch 222
jedes Demokraten unwürdig
bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer ist jetzt
bei uns im Studio sozialtourismus oder
dringend benötigte Hilfe für Menschen
die vor dem Krieg hier zu uns nach
Deutschland fliehen ist das
gerechtfertigt hat er damit Recht
ja das ist die große Debatte die das
politische Berlin heute diskutiert und
sicherlich viele viele Menschen im Land
auch in Deutschland diskutieren werden
die Frage kommen ukrainische Flüchtlinge
zu uns um hier und ich sage jetzt mal
ganz drastisch
Sozialleistungen abzustauben und um dann
wieder zurück in die Ukraine zu gehen
was Friedrich Merz gesagt hat ist ja
dass er sagt die kommen die gehen zurück
die kommen die gehen zurück was
Friedrich Merz bisher nicht gesagt hat
ist wie viele es eigentlich sind die
genau das machen diese Zahlen die bleibt
er schuldig und solange es da keine
greifbaren Zahlen auch gibt ist die
Debatte natürlich anders zu führen muss
man sie sicherlich einfach als eine eine
cdu-taktische Debatte auch sehen wir
sind dabei uns zum Zahlen aus allen
Bereichen die es gibt zu bemühen und zu
bekommen faktum ist das viele Verbände
auch in Deutschland bisher diese
Einschätzung die Friedrich Merz dort
gerade oder bei Bild gestern Abend zu
Besten gegeben hat nicht richtig decken
können ja du sagst die Zahlen fehlen auf
welcher Grundlage basiert also diese
Aussage oder ist das rein politisches
Kalkül was er da macht was wir wissen
ist dass viele Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine und sind ja meist Frauen und
Kinder hier Antrag auf Asyl stellen dann
auch quasi die Leistungen seit Sommer
bekommen die ein Hartz IV Empfänger
bekommt und das ist glaube ich ganz
verständlich auch immer mal wieder kurz
zurückfahren in ihr Land um zu gucken
wie geht es eigentlich den Männern wie
geht es meinem Ehemann der
möglicherweise an der Front kämpft der
vielleicht kurz einmal nach Hause kommen
ist wie geht es Hab und Gut also steht
die Wohnung noch steht das Häuschen noch
ich glaube das ist ganz Männchen das ist
selbstverständlich und das ist das was
Friedrich merzia sagt die gehen zurück
die kommen dann wieder die gehen zurück
und die kommen dann wieder
und in dieser Situation eine Debatte
zumindest auf diese Menschen über
sozialtourismus aufzumachen das trifft
glaube ich den Nagel überhaupt nicht auf
den Kopf anders ist die Frage ob es aus
anderen Ländern Asylbewerber gibt die
genau nach diesem Musterverfahren wir
haben mit ihm auch Entschuldigung über
über die Energie im Land gesprochen die
drohenden Blackouts jetzt im Winter das
ist seine Antwort bei die richtigen
Fragen gestern Abend
ein Blackout ist ja nicht irgendwas
sondern es ist schlicht dunkel dann für
eine Zeit in Deutschland das wäre vorher
vor einem Jahr noch völlig undenkbar
gewesen kann eine Regierung sowas
durchhalten Blackout in Deutschland also
lassen wir uns mal nur auf wenige
Minuten Stromausfall oder vielleicht
einige Stunden Stromausfall die hiesige
Bürgermeisterin hält das ja für
verträglich lassen Sie mal drei Stunden
in den Kliniken in Berlin den
stromausfallen oder in den großen
Kühlhäusern den stromausfallen wir
werden schon nach einer Stunde
Stromausfall merken welchen
volkswirtschaftlichen Schaden das
anrichtet wir können uns das in diesem
Land nicht leisten und wir müssen es
auch nicht akzeptieren wenn wir eine
bessere Regierung also das stünde in der
Verantwortung der Regierung das steht
allein in der Verantwortung dieser
Regierung die wertvollste Zeit vertan
hat mit Streitereien ohne die Probleme
wirklich zu lösen er kritisiert also
ganz klar die Regierung hat er damit
recht damit hat er in gewisser Weise
recht wir wissen auch das was die
ampelregierung bestehen aus SPD grün und
FDP derzeit aus sitzen muss das ist
natürlich entstanden unter einer
CDU-geführten Regierung nämlich der von
Angela Merkel in der zu großen Teilen
die SPD immer beteiligt war also die
Regierung der auch dann zumindest der
Partei Friedrich Merz angehört hat also
der kann er sich nicht ganz rausreden
dass es immer schwierig aber am Ende ist
natürlich richtig und wir werden wieder
bei der Frage landen was machen wir wenn
drohende Blackouts sind ist es dann
sinnvoll beispielsweise Kernkraftwerke
zum Jahresende abzuschalten die wie wir
alle wissen Strom produzieren und sagt
man die müssen auf jeden Fall am Netz
bleiben und wir brauchen auch noch mehr
Kohlekraftwerke beispielsweise so bitter
es ist die den Strom produzieren viele
Politiker haben schon Vorschläge gemacht
man sollte sich einfach noch einen
zweiten Pulli 1 anziehen etwas ja dicker
anziehen um diesen Winter um der Energie
eben vorzubeugen dass es nicht zum
Blackout kommt aber ist das ganze denn
so einfach ja das sind eigentlich für
eine Volkswirtschaft wie die Deutsche
und für ein Land in dem wir leben mit so
einem hohen Wohlstandsniveau
unwürdig dass es solche Vorschläge gibt
wir gehen wenn man beispielsweise auch
an die Schulen denkt jetzt in den
dritten Winter mit dem Schulkinder hier
in Deutschland mit einem extra Pullover
und einer Winterjacke mutmaßlich im
Klassenzimmer sitzen wir hatten zwei
corona-jahre die in ganz viel gelüftet
wurde und ist dort sehr sehr zügig war
in den Klassenzimmern jetzt kommt die
Energiekrise dazu in der in einigen
Schulen Heizungen nicht mehr hochgedreht
werden oder zum Teil dann muss auch
wegen Corona wieder gelüftet werden also
diese arme Armen schulkämmer finden sich
in einer Situation in der man sagen muss
das ist dieses Landes nicht würdig und
die Bundesregierung ist wirklich
gefordert alles zu tun damit es nicht zu
einem Strom Engpass kommt meine Sicht
auf die Dinge ist folgende ich glaube da
wird nicht alles getan da herrscht
parteipolitisches Taktieren da herrscht
viel Ideologie und genau das was wir
eigentlich bräuchten nämlich einen
dramatischen Zukauf an Strom
erzeugungsmöglichkeiten der passiert
nicht es klingt auch so einfach also ich
meine wir Bürger kriegen es vielleicht
noch hin mal irgendwie ein bisschen
weniger zu heizen vielleicht mal ganz
kurz den Strom auszumachen aber dann
fängt das schon an dann sind die
Gefrierschränke bei uns die dann schon
dran sind die Lebensmittel Läden die
wenn sie nicht mehr melken können also
ich meine wie soll damit umgegangen
werden es klingt viel zu einfach genau
das eine war jetzt die Frage nach dem
Pullover ziehe ich mir einfach ein
wärmeren Pullovern das kann ich machen
wenn ich abends ins Bett gehe
beispielsweise und keine Heizung im
Schlafzimmer habe oder auch im
Wohnzimmer das ist alles möglich wir
reden über das Thema schulen wir reden
dann aber beim Thema Strom natürlich
auch über Industriebetriebe wir reden
über Krankenhäuser viele haben
vorgesorgt es gibt Notstromaggregate
ganz klar weil es natürlich immer mal zu
Stromausfällen kommen kann wenn es im
letzten Überlastung gibt aber hier reden
wir ja über staatlich verordnete
Stromabschaltungen das ist noch mal
etwas ganz anderes und das zeigt in
welchen Dilemma wir uns befinden das
zeigt wie verfehlt die Politik von der
Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel in 16
Jahren gewesen war die sehr stark auf
russisches Gas und Abhängigkeiten
gesetzt hat und die zeigt aber auch wie
wichtig es ist dass wir bei den Strom
erzeugen nicht nur auf Wind und Sonne
setzen sondern auch beispielsweise auf
die Kernkraft Energiekrise und auch die
Vielzahl von Krisen die wir aktuell
haben eigentlich eine echte Chance für
jede Opposition nach Corona jetzt also
die Energiekrise dazu der Krieg zwischen
Russen und Ukrainern und die Deutschen
haben immer mehr Angst da reingezogen zu
werden Kritik an der Regierung gibt es
also genug aber was wäre denn nun
eigentlich wenn wäre die Union
regierungsbereit
sind sie Standby könnten sie heute
übernehmen die Opposition von heute ist
immer die Regierung von morgen aber wir
arbeiten nicht auf den Crash dieser
Regierung wenn es nötig wäre wären wir
selbstverständlich in der Lage zu
übernehmen das ist überhaupt keine Frage
aber noch einmal wir müssen in der
gegenwärtigen Situation ein gemeinsames
Interesse daran haben dass dieses Land
gut regiert wird ich habe allerdings
Zweifel wenn eine Regierung und ein
Bundeskanzler noch nicht einmal in der
Lage ist seine eigene Regierung
zusammenzuhalten dann wird da wenig Zeit
darauf verwenden können noch andere mit
ins Boot zu nehmen
also ich meine die Abhängigkeit von
russischem Gas das alles du hast das
vorhin schon gesagt hat die CDU
mitzuverantworten könnte sie jetzt aber
tatsächlich diese Krise besser meistern
also würde die CDU ist besser
hinbekommen Aussicht des
Oppositionsführers und Friedrich Mertes
ein erfahrene Oppositionsführer gibt es
natürlich ein Jahr nach einer verlorenen
Bundestagswahl gar keine andere
Antwortmöglichkeit als zu sagen
natürlich könnte ich das besser wir
haben uns konsolidiert und ich könnte
sofort aus dem Stand die Regierung
übernehmen das ist ganz klar das muss er
sagen ich glaube das erwarten natürlich
die Wähler auch alles andere wäre
schlimm und wäre ein Desaster für ihn
und für seine Partei aber die Frage ist
ja am Ende wer hätte ein Interesse diese
Regierung jetzt auch platzen zu lassen
so muss man das ja auch einmal sehen und
da muss man einfach sagen weder die SPD
mit ihrem Bundeskanzler hätte mit Blick
auf die aktuellen Wahlumfragen ein
Interesse SPD liegt unter 20 Prozent das
heißt sie würde definitiv nicht den
nächsten Bundeskanzler stellen und auch
die FDP der kleinste Partner hat kein
Interesse liegt in den Umfragen derzeit
bei 7 bis 8%, also auch deutlich unter
dem der Bundestag war das würde bedeuten
dass auch Abgeordnete ihren Job im
Parlament verlieren würden und immer
wenn es dazu kommt zur Frage ist es
eigentlich sinnvoll dass ich meinen Job
möglicherweise nicht mehr in der
nächsten Parlament antrete und habe dann
ist es meistens so dass das eine
bindende Wirkung hat dass die
Parlamentarier sagen nein nein diese
Regierung lassen wir besser mal nicht
platzen wir machen weiter selbst wenn es
ein weiterwurscheln ist lass uns gern
mal
auf die Fragen schauen ist es vielleicht
auch so schwierig diese Energiekrise zu
lösen weil die Parteien an ihren
Ideologien festhalten vielleicht
vorweggeschoben einmal diese Krise die
wir hier erleben die übersteigt
wahrscheinlich alles was wir in den
letzten Jahrzehnten gesehen haben Frau
Merkel hatte viele Krisen zu bewältigen
aber immer in Etappen und hier kommt
jetzt ganz ganz viel zusammen und wir
sehen in diesem Ranking sehr spannend
Annalena baerbock die
bundesaußenministerin ist aktuell die
beliebteste Politikerin und dann folgen
eigentlich auf die nächsten Plätzen erst
auf Platz sechs ein weiterer
Bundesminister also jemand der derzeit
hier entführt das gesamte Land
Verantwortung trägt aber der tritt
derzeit gar nicht so in Erscheinung denn
Cem Özdemir als Agrarminister ist jetzt
nicht unbedingt die Figur die man
täglich im Fernsehen sieht weil die
Themen vielleicht gar nicht so stark auf
der Agenda stehen der Bundeskanzler erst
auf Platz 7 Friedrich Merz auf Platz 8
und dann kommt der ehemalige Liebling
vieler Deutschen Robert Habeck
abgestürzt mittlerweile auf Platz
noch da kommt sicherlich zweierlei
zusammen Robert Habeck hat einen
hammerharten Job zu meistern in der
aktuellen Krise ist eine Wirtschafts
Energiekrise er ist Wirtschafts- und
Energieminister ganz klar das heißt das
prasselt alles auf ihn ein aber er hat
seinen Ministerium auch wirklich
entkernt muss man sagen hat die oberste
Führungsebene ausgetauscht hat viele
Fachleute ausgetauscht und dafür seine
grünen Parteifreunde oder grüne Fans um
sich geschart und da ist immer die Frage
wenn es nach Partei Politik geht oder
auch nach Partei Ideologie ist dass das
Richtige für ein Land wie Deutschland
ist es nicht besser eher auf Kompetenz
zu setzen und das genau fliegt Robert
habe ich jetzt um die Ohren vielen Dank
bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer für diese
Einordnung
[Musik]